ça ne déséquilibre pas le texte ça le
durcit puisque par définition ces
amendements étaient destinés à améliorer
la situation des seniors dans le monde
du travail était sur les critères de
pénibilité était également
c'était des éléments pour justement que
les gens se disent en cas de carrière
pénible en cas de difficultés il y a
quand même des adoucisseurs dans ce
texte on savait soyons France avait dans
le débat sénatorial on savait que
certains d'entre eux étaient très
limites pour par rapport à un pdfss et
pouvait être cavaliers sociaux donc le
Conseil constitutionnel les a rejetés ça
nous laisse le texte d'origine brut ce
qui veut dire que forcément alors le
ministère c'était des gens pressé
lorsqu'on avait évoqué le fait qu'il
soit censuré de nous dire il serait
repris dans un texte travail sauf que le
texte travail on nous l'annonce pour le
mois de juin sans concertation avec les
syndicats avant ou à peine un mois ça
n'est pas tenable donc faudrait que tout
le monde se mette autour de la table et
se disent bon si on faisait les choses
dans les règles en respectant le
dialogue classique et la procédure
classique ce serait plus simple pour
tout le monde